hello YouTube just love Ursula friends
this is goon Jan here
welcome to the seventh episode of dirty
chess tricks against Sicilian in this
episode I'm going to show you one of the
modern trick of 2016
against the exited dragon the excited
dragon or Isis after the Mordor efore
see fire and now black fall off with the
Moon Knight to c6 and the move g6
it is very reliable and a safe option
and that's why it is very popular at the
club level now in this modern world
where you have the excess of mega
database live book and many other
resources which can tell you what your
opponent plays and if you find out that
your opponent plays nothing other than
exited dragon then the trick I'm about
to show you it's worth trying even in
the professional tournaments the setup
I'm going to recommend start with the
move Knight to c3 so the black continue
here with the move Knight to c6 and now
you play the move d3 black no order to
continue with the move g6 and now you
play the move Bishop to e3 and this is
something I most like about this trick
the opening variation is very much
forceful and black has to know exactly
how is going to respond to avoid a lot
of pitfalls now the first point to
notice is this Bishop is attacking the
c5 so the black response is force black
has to defend that pawn now there are
three ways black and try to defend this
pawn amongst them b6 and night to d4
gives white a clear-cut advantage and in
fact those moves are hardly played in
any professional to nerds
nevertheless I have covered those lines
in detail in the PGN which is available
in the description so kindly go through
the PGM just to give you a highlight a
higher ranked opponent place to b6
against me I responded with the Moody
and now after pawn captures Bishop
captures Knight to have six other moves
already covered in the PGN ePHI Knight
to h5 and now the wonderful move e six
so white is attacking the rook my
opponent captured the bishop I first of
all give him this check and after King
takes Queen captures it's already a
difficult position to play as a black
the problem here is black cannot play
the move Bishop to g7 because of the
simple Queen to defy and black is going
to lose rook in the corner so that's not
good
and if Knight to f6 which happens in the
game then the simplest is you continue
with the move Knight to f3 and now some
devastation happening on two squares
which cannot be avoided so for example
in this game
my opponent continued with the move
Bishop to g7 I played Knight check and
after King to g8 and Knight to e6 it's
already clear that black is going to
lose an exchange
okay so let's consider the most obvious
response from the black that is d6 well
after d6 we are going through the move
deform attacking the pawn one more time
so black has to forcefully capture this
pawn afterwards will take with the
bishop now callen-lorde moves such as f6
will only weaken black King and in those
cases right and always continue with the
move Knight to f3 so the question is
what black can do to defend the rook now
the obvious move Knight to f6 is very
bad in this position the simple reason
is after Bishop captures and pawn
captures Black has some horrible pawn
structures which can be exploited later
part in the game so that's not good
either
and apart from Knight to f6 what are the
good option
well I'm afraid there are not many for
example if black plays the move e5 then
after the move Bishop to e3 it's not
clear that what this g6 move is all
about because black can never play the
move Bishop to g7 as his d6 pawn will
become C
week so all in all night capsules defy
is the only Cedars try by the black in
this position after Knight captures and
Queen captures once again white is
hitting the rook and black is forced to
play Knight to f6
the reason Aoife is even worse in this
situation is here white can exploit this
immediately after the more Queen to b4
check now let me highlight the problem
in the black camp by showing you one of
my game where my opponent continued with
the move Bishop to d7 I responded with
the move Queen to b3 attacking b7 and
after the modern Bishop to c6 Bishop to
c4 attacking the pawn Queen to c7 and
now the Moon Knight to d5 that Knight is
too much dangerous so it has to be
removed so my opponent captured with the
bishop but after Bishop captures once
again black face the same situation
where he cannot place Bishop to g7 and
in this case even not Bishop to e7 on
top of everything he's b7 points also
hang my opponent continue here with the
move rook to b8 but this is a big time
mistake before I move on I like you to
pause this video and find out what is
wrong with this move
ok I hope you find this move that is
Queen to be Phi Jack if the King moves
then the black position already collapse
so my opponent continued here with the
move Queen to d7
but after Bishop to f7 check a
deflection move King to e7 and now the
simplest move Queen to b3 and not only
white emerge with an extra pawn but the
black King caught in the center so in
other words here the only reply left for
the black is Knight to f6 no matter what
will continue with his energetic play
with the move ePHI so now attacking to
sports and once again black responds his
force black has to accept this pawn if
he try to run away and this happened in
many games especially below 2000 where
my opponent casually played the
Knight to d7 which is outright blunder
can you find the refutation yep is
ethics very simple attacking two sports
so the black response is false black has
to play Knight to f6 saving both the
threat but now comes Bishop to b5 check
and black is completely busted
so that means force reply over here is
pawn captures ePHI afterwards why it has
this sneaky move Bishop to b5 check
kindly note if Knight to d7 at this
point then after queen capture c5 rope
to b8 and castle on the Queen side it's
a big time question where this king will
go so that's not good and the most
obvious mu that is Bishop to d7
afterwards white will continue with the
MU Queen captures e fi and this is a
standard position by forced almost you
reach it and that is why this is so
effective now here black has tried few
replies but amongst them the only right
move over here is a6
wrist all moves leads to the disaster
for the black let's see them
now the first and obvious move black
plays over here is Bishop to g7 but this
is outright mistake because now white
can do castle on the Queen side so that
Bishop is attack twice and because that
nighti spin black has to do something to
unpin this Knight the logical reply
looks like castle on the King side with
support the bishop but now comes Bishop
captures Knight captures and now Queen
to be Phi and black loses the whole
piece and so far I have found so many
even higher rank players has fallen into
this now it is not simple as it looks
because black has some counters but
white will come out from all this let me
show you what I mean so one of my
opponent who is around 2100 rate 8
continue with the move
shop capture c3 and after pawn captures
he played the move Queen to b6 I
responded with the move Queen captures
d7 and he continued his attack with the
move rook to d8 no matter I continue
with the move Queen captures e7 my
opponent captured the rook I captured
with the King and now some force checks
happens so he played Queen check King to
e2 Queen check King to have three Queen
check but after Queen to e3 blocking the
check white is all set to get out his
pieces
my opponent continued with the move
Queen to even I responded with the moon
g3 and after Queen captures and the move
Knight to e2 white emerged with a piece
for two pawns which is more than
sufficient winning advantage if you play
accurately kindly go through the rest of
the game from the PGN the second move
black and try over here is Bishop to c6
but I think after Bishop captures and
pawn captures black has some severe
long-range problems and here I should
continue with his normal development
plan such as Knight to f3 Bishop to g7
rook to d1 Queen to b6 and now castle on
the Kings side so white is continuously
pressurizing the e7 square and not only
that there is Knight to e4 coming in to
mix and then B 3 and C 4 will follow I
know you are thinking what happens if
black twins simply capture this pawn
well this is a trap where white can play
a rope to be won and after Queen to c2
rook to be a check rook captures and
Queen captures Queen to d7 Queen
captures came to b6 and black can hardly
survive from this position
okay now let's consider the most
accurate response by the black that is a
six after this move
why should certainly capture this bishop
and after Queen captures Knight to f3
Bishop to g7 and the move rook to d1
black is still facing some severe
problems now mainly there are three good
replies by the black over here but
against each of them white has some
nasty ideas now the first response I
want to cover his Queen to g4 when after
that why should certainly castle on the
Kings side leave black castle then the
e7 pawn Hanks and if black plays a6 at
this point then white has this lethal
move Queen to d6 which stop black to
castle on the Kings side this is a case
of my game against her 1800 rated player
where he continued with the move Bishop
to her fate I played Queen to c7
attacking the pawn and now that pawn
cannot move because of the simple Queen
to c6 Chaka my opponent continued here
with the move Bishop to e7
but after Queen captures rook to d8 rook
captures Bishop captures White has this
winning move Knight to e5 and black
completely busted the second Queen move
black and try over here is Queen to c6
afterwards I am recommending that you
should castle on the Kings side and
after the most dangerous reply Knight to
h5 attacking the Queen you should
continue with the move Queen to e3 now
at first sight this looks very risky
because after Bishop captures pawn
captures and the move look to c8 it
looks like White has some weaknesses on
the Queen side but after the following
continuation that is rook to d3
it turns out that black has more
weaknesses on the Kings side and
especially the dark squares are
tremendously weak Kylene OD black plays
c6 then g4 is a very strong reply so one
of my game continued here
with the Makassar on the kingside I
responded with the moon look to even
pressurizing the e7 my opponent
responded with the moon e 6 but after
Queen to at six there's a threat of
Knight to g5 so my opponent defend it
with the Moon Knight to f6
but after Knight to g5 rook to b8 and
now rook to a3 it is very clear that it
is only white who is doing attacking in
such a situation
my opponent continued here with the move
Queen to be Phi his idea is when I
played night to at 7 he responded with a
tricky move Queen to e5 but afterwards
next reply that is Queen to see one
black has to forcefully play Queen to a5
but then rook to f3 happens and now
there is no way black can save this
piece in the game he played Queen
captures and after pawn captures and
night to at 7 black has given up the
Queen and a pawn for the two pieces
which is never going to be enough
compensation last but not least the base
reply over here is Queen to a5 which I
doubt hardly any of the operand will
consider because of the double pond but
never the mind here a White has a
stronger reply that is castle on the
Kings side now I like to show you one of
my model game in this line which will
give you a very good idea how you can
handle such a positions in this game my
opponent continued with the move Queen
captures highly capture with the night
and now he castle on the Kings side I
played Knight to e4 and now my opponent
attacked the c2 pawn with the move rook
to c8 and after the move c3 he played
rook F to d8 and it's very national plan
for the black ass that two rooks are
posted on open files but this is exactly
white once I continue with the move
Knight to b6 attacking the rook rook to
b8 is the only reply but then comes the
wonderful moon f4 and it turns out that
night cannot move the
simple reason is let's say if Knight to
e4 then Knight e to d7 and black is
going to lose in exchange so more or
less black is forced to find an
alternative and my opponent indeed find
the one he continued here with the movie
six and after the moon g4 he plays his
knight on the D Phi square no matter I
continue with the Moon Knight captures
and after rook captures rook captures
pawn captures and the move rook to d1
black has a weak pawn on the D Phi
square which can be the target for the
rest of the game now if you open and
continue here with the marouk to d8 the
knight to f3 is very strong reply so in
the game my opponent continued here with
the move Bishop captures but after pawn
captures rope to DA
why does a simple plan that is king to
f2 and the King March is going to prove
very decisive now just to illustrate my
point
my opponent continued here with the MU
King to g7 and after came to e3 he
played h5 which is in fact weak more
because after pawn captures pawn
captures and now the MU c4 black has
lost upon and in fact the game I hope
with this tricky weapon now you can give
a shock to many of your tournament
opponent the good point about this trick
is the line is very forceful in the
opening and not my excited dragon player
are ready to face it well thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
so closing for the kill and there he
goes bang checkmate and Korchnoi can't
believe is shaking the clock he thinks
of hundreds run out time but no
he made it but to my surprise I found
out that there are some very nasty traps
exist and that start with this move by
white which is Bishop to c4